- Welcome back.
All hour, we have celebrated
how powerful music can be
in our lives, releasing interviews
from musicians we've never aired before.
Now I wanna share some music
from an emerging artist who's
all about using their songs
to advocate for others.
They've been featured in
Billboard and Rolling Stone,
now performing "Disappear" off
their latest album Pillbox,
give It Up for Grace Gaustad.
(audience applause)
♪ You probably don't have
the worst intentions ♪
♪ You just know how to hurt me the best ♪
♪ From a distance ♪
♪ A distance ♪
♪ I never thought you'd make me cry ♪
♪ But there's nothing behind your eyes ♪
♪ Got my reasons ♪
♪ I wish I ♪
♪ I could make you disappear ♪
♪ Tell myself I never cared ♪
♪ Trying to cut you out ♪
♪ Like a stain in my carpet ♪
♪ Weeds in my garden ♪
♪ I wish I ♪
♪ I could make you disappear ♪
♪ Keep you anywhere but here ♪
♪ You're so had to hate
when I'm safe in your arms ♪
♪ Now I'm counting scars ♪
♪ I wish I ♪
♪ I could make you disappear ♪
♪ Find you in somebody else ♪
♪ Without all the bad parts ♪
♪ I'm doing this for myself ♪
♪ I can't fix who you are ♪
♪ I never thought you'd make me cry ♪
♪ But there's nothing behind your eyes ♪
♪ Got my reasons ♪
♪ I wish I ♪
♪ I could make you disappear ♪
♪ Tell myself I never cared ♪
♪ Trying to cut you out ♪
♪ Like a stain in my carpet ♪
♪ Weeds in my garden ♪
♪ I wish I ♪
♪ I could make you disappear ♪
♪ Keep you anywhere but here ♪
♪ You're so hard to hate ♪
♪ When I'm safe in your arms ♪
♪ Now I'm counting scars ♪
♪ I wish I ♪
♪ I could make you disappear ♪
♪ Always end up with the wrong obsession ♪
♪ Keep on walking in the wrong direction ♪
♪ Maybe this is where I learn my lesson ♪
♪ Leave no question ♪
♪ I could make you disappear ♪
♪ Tell myself I never cared ♪
♪ You're so hard to hate ♪
♪ When I'm safe in your arms ♪
♪ Now I'm counting scars ♪
♪ I wish I ♪
♪ I could make you disappear ♪
(crowd applause)
- One more time, give it up
for Grace Gaustad everybody.
Pick up their new album, Pillbox
wherever you get your music (indistinct).